foreign
start by can I nominate as chairman
councilor Mark Durham do I have a second
do we have any other proposals
and um I think councilor Durham is
elected as chair
thank you very much everybody
um and then uh in terms of a vice
chairman of Northwest committee uh from
the chair
I would like to nominate councilor Mrs
Thompson I'll second
yes
sorry when you said for the committee
are we doing just for tonight no this is
this is because this is
as we would do at the statutory annual
right
not according to Mr quelch but um it
doesn't make any difference but
okay well just tonight that's fine yeah
sorry it's not the Thai object either
way no no no I mean it's absolutely fine
I did check
it's a it's a very good point so okay
um is it necessary for me to move
before you begin officially mate I have
half a minute of the committee's time
please please thank you um
thank you chairman um as of the outgoing
chairman
um we missed unfortunately the last
meeting was canceled so I couldn't say
at the end of the municipal year where I
normally would which is thank you very
much to all your men all the members for
your contributions
um thank you to those not here perhaps
are watching glued to YouTube
um thank you to all our officers Mr
Johnson Miss Sandler Mrs herner thank
you to our committee clerks who's been
miss Verna Casey for some years and now
Mr Jones who I can't see so I suppose
he's there
um thank you everyone for your
contributions and all the members of the
public who spoke and thank you Jim
thank you well thank you councilor
Thompson you did an excellent job in
this position for a long time and I'm
sure
um
everybody uh
agrees with that and um
and I was going to say welcome to yes we
do yes Welcome to our um
new members but of course we haven't got
any new members we we lost some we
gained some but they are not not here so
um no thank you that for that um cancer
Thompson so
um
excuse my croaky voice
I picked up a cold I didn't pick up
anything worse last week but um as far
as I know
and I did have to conduct a funeral this
morning so I just made that I just made
it through there hopefully I will do
tonight as well so good evening and
welcome to this Northwest planning
committee on the 24th of
May 2024 my name is councilor Mark
Durham and I'm the chairman of this
committee for this occasion members we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up to indicate whether you
wish to speak I'll then invite you at
the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphone therefore
can ask when invited you speak
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the gender
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and please
avoid repetition of points previously
made item two apologies for absence
from absence of councilors uh huge civil
and Council within supporter okay thank
you Joe thank you very much indeed item
three minutes is recommended that the
meetings of the minutes of the meeting
held on
it says looking down at the date of the
meeting somebody help me before I get to
it 8th of March thank you councilor
Stevens
um
or approved as a true and accurate
record members those were there thank
you very much indeed
um so I did I have a proposal secondary
for that counselor Thompson
councilor Stevens
thank you very much indeed
item for Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests or
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
of you are reminded that you are
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as you become aware should the
need arise during the meeting council
Mrs Thompson thank you I have to declare
a peculiary interest and therefore will
leave the chamber for item on the agenda
numbers
arms to land immediately around that
property so thank you councilman
Thompson any other Declarations of
Interest
there are none
um item five we get into the reports so
who is dealing with this first one
okay
thank you
um
take it away
thank you chairman
so this application is a full
application for 17 dwellings within the
settlement boundary of tollsbury and to
the
outpatient is for all Market dwellings
which will be made up of two one-bedroom
properties six two bedroom properties
and nine three bedroom properties
it follows a previously refused
application for nine properties one of
the principal concerns with that
application was the ineffective use of
land and an inappropriate housing mix
because they were large properties and a
low density across the site
so this is the location plan
historically there was a bus depot
within the site um which has now been
demolished
and here we have the proposed site plan
you see we have
um semi-detached and link attached
um property fronting new road with a
block of eight Flats within the center
of the site carports and parking at bin
store and cycle store to serve those
properties and then um ones attached and
two pairs of semi-detached dwellings
runs in Festival Road
so the M layout follows the same
principles of the as a previously refuse
yeah refuse scheme but there was no
concerns in relation to the layout or
the impacts and the character and
appearance of the area raised for that
application
here we have the proposed elevations for
the properties that would front New Road
and their floor plans so these would be
two bedroom properties
and roof plan just for reference
and here's the Street Scenes you can see
that the um properties follow the visual
cues of The Terraces that exist in the
street scene and then the the hip on the
roof here
um follows the visual cues of the
neighboring properties and then just a
street scene below showing what was
existing at the site previously
this is the elevations of the
blocks of flats so they're within the
access road within the site
and their floor plans
and roof plan
and then here's the carpool
um bin and cycle store elevations and
floor plans to serve those
so they we move on to the properties
that would front first ball road so this
is plus 13 and 14 which is three bedroom
properties
plots 15 and 16 which free beds send me
to touch pairs
and then plot 17 which is a detached
three bed
we have the street scene proposed for
first of all road and you can see there
detached property and reduces the bulk
of the development As you move along the
street scene to the
um single story property
so just for your reference this is the
previously review scheme so you can see
it was a lot lower density with Garden
sizes well in excess of um what we would
require and more spread of Development
Across the site
and there's just the straight scenes of
the previous game
so we have some recent site photos so
this is the site here you see the um
demolition Works have taken place under
what was a previously approved scheme in
2017.
just some views of the neighboring area
so this is still new road and then this
moves on to Hassler road which is
the road
um
so the site would lie Behind these
properties here so it wouldn't actually
front onto Hustler Road at all and then
moving on to First wool road so these
dwellings are opposite the site
and then here's the site within Festival
Road
and existing neighboring properties
so a members update has been circulated
and I hope that it followed but the
strike the strike through text was text
to be removed and the red is the
additional text it provides a correction
of the word in in relation to the
external lighting section of the report
um and but the main point is update to
the five year housing land Supply which
I know you're all aware of we can now
demonstrate 6.35 years worth of housing
however the site is within the
settlement boundary
um
reason for the update was from when the
when the report was originally published
and to be then put on the agenda that
was before the meeting that took place
last week and was the official figure so
that's why with reports with these
committees we've had to make this this
this amendment to just so members
understand that
thank you Mr Jones
thank you yeah so they so we had the
fiber housing land supplier but this
site is within the settlement boundary
and so regardless of 5V housing and
supplier figure is deemed sustainable
and in principle would be supported
under the ldp
the site is also previously developed
land that will be brought back into a
use
um rather than developing a Greenfield
site and it's considered to provide a
more appropriate use within a
residential area
um because this isn't particularly
appealing for employment use
so sites like this that officers think
that the council should be looking to
support as it will help to maintain the
five-year housing land supplier and the
mppf also recognizes the importance of
small and medium sites in in that they
can be brought forward quickly the
development provides an appropriate mix
of Housing and the design is sympathetic
to the surrounding area and the
developer is also willing to enter into
a section one and six agreement to
secure the necessary Financial
contributions towards Healthcare and
Rams so the I guess the negative of the
scheme is that there would be no
affordable housing provided but we have
had an independent viability assessment
undertaken of the applicant's viability
assessment and it was deemed that the
site wouldn't be available for
affordable housing so in weigh in the
benefits against that harm the officers
are recommending the application for
approval thank you chairman
um thank you very much Mrs Hannah um
have we got any public speakers
no speakers on this
okay thank you very much indeed members
oh everybody's got their hands out right
uh councilor Molly then councilor White
councilman Stevens
Morgan and Thompson okay well in the
order I saw you cancel a Morley first
yeah thank you chairman
um well from
what we were discussing today I was
surprised that there aren't any
affordable housing we're pretty low on
that anyway at the moment and
trying to meet that criteria they think
it's going to get steadily worse
also which is the proposed or the
preferred access route to here because I
know when you go down Station Road it's
pretty the parking's awful there
is there like a
a way
preferred route through thirstable Road
I can't remember if that's blocked off
it looks like there's a line there but
that was already those two things thank
you
foreign
in terms of the affordable housing
because the site is previously developed
land
um and there'll be Works required such
as remediation it has been found that it
isn't viable but it will still
contribute to the five year housing land
Supply
um in the sense of bringing forward
Market dwellings and the
density of this game is probably the
greatest it could be
um in achieving an effective use of land
um
but in in doing that still doesn't make
it viable to provide affordable housing
unfortunately but
this site is within assessment boundary
and is is sustainable
and then in terms of the access road to
the access to the flats will be
um off of new road and so yeah it would
be up through Station Road yeah either
three festival or New Road
thank you
um can I ask you mentioned it was an
independent viability assessment
um can you just explain that please
so the applicant submit a viability
assessment with the application and then
we
um go out to a viability consultant to
assess that for us so it's independent
of the council but also independent of
the applicant
thank you councilor White
thank you Mr yeah I mean not providing
affordable housing it goes against all
of our policies and if the site's not
viable the site's not viable I just
think they should find an alternative
use for it I don't see why we're we're
supporting it against all my policies
I've also got a query with the
development line I think that the
development's contrived with the
development in the middle
um it doesn't match the linear design of
the houses front and back they've all
got long Gardens and they don't have
houses in the middle so I think that'll
cause overlooking to the houses either
side
um I don't think there's there's going
to be a limit with parking I don't know
if it meets the parking um I presume it
does meet the parking standards but can
you show me where the both sides I think
one side has got it meets the building
line is the other side slightly further
I know is about the same
it's a little bit further yeah
yeah I mean I mean for me it's the
overlooking front and back I don't think
is acceptable particularly as we don't
have the benefit of the affordable
housing and I think if it's an unviable
site it's non-viable site so for me I
think that that is a material
consideration and I think the developers
should come back with something where we
can provide affordable housing we're low
on we haven't met come to the meeting
today we haven't met our current where
we should be on affordable housing so to
allow 17 more houses and not a single
affordable
it's not our fault if it's not viable
thank you this is hurting you
thank you um in terms of the alternative
use so the site was an employment site
but there wasn't actually any employees
on the site just as it was used as a bus
depot this was something that was
accepted under the 2017 application and
so could be seen unreasonable for us to
alter that stance at this stage
in terms of the viability the affordable
housing policy does allow for us to
accept no provision of affordable
housing as long as it's Justified and
I'd say with this application there's
been clear justification as to why it
would be
the MPP also requires us to place
substantial benefit on bringing
previously developed land back into use
and not using Greenfield language I
think is a significant benefit
and then I think the other point was in
relation to parking yes it does meet the
requirements and then overlooking we've
got sufficient back-to-back distances
um 25 meters or over which is required
by the design guys so I didn't have any
concerns in respect of overlooking
thank you
uh councilor Stevens you're next
thank you chair
so I'm the ward member for tolsbury so I
know the site's extremely well obviously
um just to pick up on one point that's
already been raised about the access on
the thirstable roadside Festival road
towards the west then becomes a private
unmade road so if we do Grant approval
for this I'd like to see some condition
about the site access during
construction that it doesn't go through
that private road because it's just the
residents there that will have to pay to
keep resurfacing that road so if we
could bear that in mind
but I'm jumping ahead a bit really
because
um I mean in some in many ways this
ticks all the boxes doesn't it it's it
makes use of previously developed land
as a Brownfield site it's within the in
the defined settlement boundary of toll
spree it's surrounded by existing
Residential Properties the scale the
design the appearance don't seem to
provide any or pose any particular harm
and it would contribute to our five-year
housing lens but I've got a whole list
of Pros down here I I could read them
all out
but I'm bitterly disappointed to find
that there's no affordable housing
proposed and it's not they're not even
proposing to give the thousand pounds or
anything and I just find that
I I it's not just disappointment I find
it unbelievable that it's zero there's
not any contribution whatsoever and I
don't accept that there must be
something they can do to be able to
contribute something to the society that
they're going to profit from
um they shouldn't obviously have paid so
much as they did
um and maybe they need to
clear the site and have a good close
look at it and then come back to the
table with some better designs that
reflect what they can afford to build
um and that for me is a real sticking
block thank you
was the application of commuted sums not
bought into the equation
for the affordable housing
it
it was found that it wasn't viable at
all to provide any contribution and
there is I appreciate not affordable
housing but there's contributions for
Rams and Healthcare and which are also
affected in
um I did I did notice the parish
council's comment that they wanted
section 106 money for Waterworks Road
which I'm assuming is the road you were
talking about councilor Stevens I'm not
sure that we can use 106 money for a
private private break but councilor
Stephen makes very valid point
that that would need to be
um off limits
um if if the committee of mind you to
approve
that Waterworks rate is protected
because it is a
a frequent um well it is a private it's
a private road so
um anyway we we can we it's outside the
development okay
yeah well I'm trying to find the
condition number I probably just can't
find at the moment but I'm sure there's
a construction management plan that's
conditioned though to ensure the ropes
for traffic so we can we can on that
thank you very much councilor Morgan
yeah thank you chairman I'm I'm just
thinking how wonderful it is to be able
to consider planning applications
without the threat of the Tilted balance
hanging Universe it's quite refreshing
um however um which means I think we can
be we can be afford to be fairly
particular in our decision as to whether
we go ahead with this situation and I
reiterate the points made uh previously
about affordable housing particularly as
the majority of the dwelling seem to be
one and two bedroom I'm just wondering
you know is there is there a perceived
demand for uh dwelling to that came to
which isn't part of us of an affordable
housing scheme I'm not quite sure
whether that with that will work I have
also picked up well the terms looking at
the bit the the medical there's been
um a comment made that the surgery
Arrangements in toolsby are already sort
of under pressure and
um
that this is only going to make that
worse and I just wanted to check the
reason I know there's the previous
application was refused uh and this one
has now been passed was that purely
based upon the density is that is that
that is that the Walters tilted it in
favor
I'll start with your last question first
if that's okay so yeah essentially if
I'll show you the last application
you can see the
the houses were two and three beds I
believe but they had um large dressing
rooms and and factors like that at the
first floor so on paper they actually
appeared as four bedroom dwellings it
could have been used that way so the
housing mix wasn't in accordance with
what we would be required and what the
needs of the district are and also the
amount of land here that it was at such
a low density the gardens were well in
excess of what would be required and so
there wasn't an effective use of land
and using the land in the best possible
way and so they there were other reasons
for a few they were the
um main principal concerns I would say
in terms of the housing mix of this
application so it's a mix of ones twos
and three beds it's
pretty much in accordance with the um
local housing needs assessment there's
just I think it's two percent more than
what the free beds and um perhaps three
percent more than two beds but I think
that happens where it's 100 Market
you're gonna have that slight skew
because you haven't got the affordable
because the splits and mix between
affordable Market but um we're talking
two or three percent so I'd say a good
mix and what the district needs
and then the health contribution so the
response is
that it's um a capacity at the moment
and that's the money that they would
need to be able to expand the surgery I
believe so the money being offered as
part of the section 106 would mitigate
against that harm
council Mrs Thompson
thank you chairman spare the repetition
of the affordable except to say you know
it's such a shame it really sticks in
the crawl but how do you argue with an
independent
Financial liability assessment very
difficult and I dare say there is
contamination on the side but leaky old
buses can't remember those buses
um
as regards
the Health Service and so on it's within
the settlement boundary there's you know
so the
principle of developments are given we
can't say it's got to be turned into
Green Space or something I'm sorry to
say I think it it is what it is
but presumably the residents of
Waterworks Road could close it
themselves no they can't we've we've
been there and got the t-shirts
councilor Stevens and I have
I've got yeah it's been sorting that out
for a long time councilor Stevens yeah I
can come back
thank you yes it's it's half a question
really so this viability assessment
looks at this proposal
yeah and finds that it's not viable to
provide affordable housing based on this
proposal but I maintain that if the
developer came back with a different
proposal perhaps using some cheaper
materials or a different design in some
way that they could make it affordable
so I don't think it's just oh well our
policy says this so therefore we've got
to let it through because they've only
done the assessment of this design
so I think we need to bear that in mind
and I remain bitterly disappointed and
rather cynical about this viability
assessment thank you
Mr Johnson here
oh yeah sorry I just wanted to add um
this is the application that we have in
front of us
the viability assessment has been
applied to this application
it's a valid
assessment and it has been
counter-assessed by
independent Financial assessors
that's a pretty much established
um protocol
in terms of viability Assessments in
planning
there's been significant numbers of
appeals on that if the viability
assessment
um
satisfies the scheme if the scheme is
satisfactory in planning terms in any
other way we can't then say to them
because we want whatever the
contribution might be yeah affordable
housing then for to mitigate the lack of
viability as in a reduced the number of
housing or or whatever the measure might
be it's really based on the application
itself so it'd be difficult if we were
to follow that line of thinking
they propose a development which because
of its scale and the extent of
remediation as required is what makes it
unviable that'd be a difficult line in
which to defend on appeal thank you
chairman
did you have anything to happen yeah it
was just in relation to the materials
that all of that is assessed as part of
the independent review and it was found
that reasonable costs had been
attributed to the material so it wasn't
that you know
um really expensive materials being used
or anything like that and I think we'd
want to be cautious of diluting the
design in any way
I'm going to play devil's advocate here
because looking at this scheme there are
a number of one bedroom
accommodation
and I can recall
um when we were discussing I think it
was the South Malden Garden suburb
councilor lights modding I think you
were that nobody wants one bedroom
properties because even somebody living
alone generally has somebody visiting
and there was actually no call for one
bedroom properties the other thing that
I'm slightly concerned about is what
what is the difference between a one or
even a two-bedroom property that is
Market or affordable
it doesn't mean that the affordable is
built to a poorer standard in which case
I don't think that that's very
acceptable what we are saying is that
affordable housing is is of a poorer
Construction
whether that's in terms of building
materials insulation etc etc and I don't
think that's entirely reasonable
um I don't know if you can answer that
and in respect of the one beds the mix
needs to be in accordance with the local
housing needs assessment
um so that's
where those have come from and there's
that's an independent study that shows
that that is what the district needs the
affordable housing so it isn't that
they're made differently they should
um they should now all be made exactly
the same and you wouldn't know it went
in the street scene which house was
affordable which isn't I think it's to
do with the
profit that the developer can make on an
affordable unit compared to a Market
unit and in relation to the purchase
price of the site and um the remediation
costs and all of those factors so it's
more about the resale price rather than
the construction costs being different
between the two types of units
so so it's developer profit
in basically yes because you you have
you have fixed costs and you have the
fixed cost which is the land
construction costs and then the variable
is the developer's profit yeah stability
is accepted that the developer is to
make a profit oh absolutely I'm not I'm
not decrying a you know profit that's
what the world spins on so but um
there's a reasonableness so um members
we haven't got a proposal on the table
yet either a councilor white yeah sorry
the application because the housing mix
doesn't meet the Shema and the actual
housing demand in the district I'm
pretty sure because I'm sure you're
right that they don't want one bedroom
Flats
certainly something that was argued in
relate I don't know
we need to be very careful about
referencing a document if that's not
what it says but I you know it's very
um
that was certainly a topic of
conversation I can
I think
it's the local housing needs assessment
so it if I can get to the point of the
report so our greatest need is for two
and three beds but it sets out a
percentage for each so I think it's up
to 10 of one bedroom properties and I've
got it here so up to one ten percent of
one beds 25 to 35 of the site has two
bedroom properties and 40 to 50 as three
bedrooms and then not relevant to this
but 10 before beds so this site would
provide 12 one beds 35 two beds and 53
three beds
so yeah it's only a two percent over
provision on the one beds okay so yeah
it's broadly whether whether there is
Market you know it's it's whether they
can sell them that's the thing of course
which is not something so um
you were almost making a proposal there
councilor white but
proposal but I can't
understand I think the the other reason
for both Pro season is that the density
doesn't density does not match the
existing
um seats street scene of predominantly
detached dwelling houses
um and bring in mind we have a five-year
lens Supply
um I think that the harm of the
development and the unsuit the design
outweigh any benefits from allowing the
development
I I'm I'm tending to think we're going
to need more robust
material considerations for well a valid
refusal councilor Morgan you're the
expert yeah certainly not
um all I was going to say I mean there's
a lot that we don't like about this site
but I'm struggling to think of a valid
reason with a material consideration on
the planning rules to refuse it so I I
move that we we go with the officers
recommendation and approve so that is
the first formal proposal and that
second It Is by counselor Mrs Thompson
so we do have a proposal on the table
to approve in line with officers
recommendations
can we have a show of hands please for
approval
that's four and those against
one abstaining
councilor Mrs Stephen I take your NoDa
syndication
so that permission is granted
subject to the 106
um and if we can do anything I think
Waterworks Road really needs looking at
if that's possible please to save my
post back and counselor Stephen's post
Bank
okay thank you members
okay next item
are we shuffling mice are we uh okay
that's good
that's fine
yeah so yes that your your interest is
Julie noted thank you councilor Thompson
we may well do so yes I'm sure we we
will find you
okay so um the next item is spittle Farm
Station Road Tolson Darcy
um I think you're going to take us
through this Sunday thank you
thank you chair
The Proposal seeks to form two dwellings
along with Associated Amenia to space
and parking facilities on two plots
within the site plot one a is a four
bedroom two-story wedding with a gross
internal floor area of 220 square meters
and plot two
um a is a three bedroom two-story dwell
in with a gross internal floor area of
147 meters squared
the current application follows the
previously refused
um application which is currently appeal
and section 3.1.12 of the officer report
sets out the changes from the previous
scheme to the current scheme which the
applicant seeks to address
um in within this application so have
the location plan
the block plants are in the two proposed
plots
these are the existing elevations
um of the of the barn that's there
these are the existing floor plans
right
sorry these are the proposed elevations
these are the proposed floor plans
the proposed roof plan
and these are the site photos I think
I'm missing a couple of extra I might be
missing a couple of slides
um within that
um
Can You Escape out sorry
I need to
so there were some additional slides
just to show comparison between the
existing
the scheme currently at appeal and the
current application just to show the
changes and the scale between
the uh three forms of the site
you just reverse a little bit so these
are the these are the proposed
elevations of the um submitted scheme
and the proposed roof plans and these
are the elevations and the roof plan of
the um previously refused application
which is currently um being heard appeal
um
where you can see some of the
significant changes which whilst the
fenestration patterns the admission of
some Dormers
and a reduction in the size and the
height
this is the existing floor plans the
proposed floor plans and that was its
um the previously refused um application
had a floor space of 430 meters squared
whereas the current scheme um has three
is a total 367 meters squared for both
the dwellings combined and approved an
approved change of use for prior
approval replication which matches the
existing elevations had a floor space
which is I think is existing 381 meters
squared
um in officers view
um and shown within the within the
slides there's very minimal difference
from within the street scene of the
proposed um applications
um however there are there's a
it's the
we just compared the two oh sorry
so this is the this is the existing as
was approved under the change of use
prior approval application as and has
currently stands on site
if we can just draw out the
the difference is if
yes although you can see between that
elevation and the currently one company
so on the on the application that's
currently uphill there are some larger
glazed areas
to the South elevation these have been
reduced
um within the current application
there's been a reduction in the Heights
of the this section of the East
Elevation
in the current application it would
match the the heights going across apart
from the pitch and within the roof plan
the previous application proposed uh
three Dormers within the roof
these have been admitted from this
scheme
with just roof
I think I think the fundamental
difference at the office is drawing out
is that vividually from the streets in
there seems to be very little difference
between the screen
and the application that we have in
front of us
justifies a similar recommendation uh to
refuse the application for the set of
reasons as in Section 8 on the report
okay thank you and we got any public
speakers on this
yes we have um
who do we have
we have
Ian o'hannon
Mr O'Hanlon do you want to find a seat
with a microphone
please take a seat there's a button on
the
with a little face like that um yeah and
you have two minutes
before it starts would it be possible to
have going po14
comparison between the two
I'm sure we can do that sorry is it do
you mean there's a there's a drawing
with the two elevations on one drawing
yes
I'm sure if that's in the presentation
the two on separate slides
I think members they've had a chance to
see them both I think yeah it is
good job
disappointing officers have that well
okay I'm sorry it's not in the pack we
can't we can't call it up so you have
two minutes from when you start to speak
and we are pretty rigid on the two
minutes so so sorry just before we start
that if you do wish for the opposite to
move between the two if that helps it
illustrate your points I think we can
accommodate that
I'll just put that out okay yeah I mean
if you might as well just toggle back
and forth so
yes
laughs
okay well thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak
um a key consideration that the
committee must take into account is the
in determining this application is is
the recognized fallback position
um it's not a matter of planning
judgment but a matter of law which must
be taken account and applied
um correctly because the fullback
position is this has class Q approval
for change abuse of the Agricultural
Bond at the application site for two
dwellings in short when considering the
planning put merits of any development
it's necessary to take into account what
could happen realistically if planning
is refused
the one then compares the proposed
development to that fullback position
when assessing any potential harm that
may be identified
the author the officer's report seeks to
reduce the weight to be given to the
full back position on the basis that the
applicant has not put forward an
argument as to why the conversion is not
being brought forward
firstly that's not a legal test but
secondly the applicant's clear intention
is to deliver a class queue scheme
should all other proposals for the
development of the application site be
turned down
um the leader court of appeal case for
the full back position Mansell versus
tombridge and malling are a council in
that case there have been prior
discussions between the council and the
planning consultant acting for the site
owners it was a clear crystal clear from
the contact that the owners were
intending one way or another to develop
the site
alternative proposals had been Advanced
seeking the council's likely reaction to
planning applications
and an application for prior approval
consent under class Q had not been
submitted
it was the judge it was in the judge's
view wholly unrealistic to imagine that
we're all such proposals to be turned
down the owner of the site would not
take advantage of the permitted
developments provided for by the class
queue to the fullest possible extent
I'm going to stop you there I'm afraid
that's the two minutes
two minutes is two minutes I'm afraid so
yeah um
um we have to be even-handed with
everybody so two minutes is literally
two minutes were there any other
speakers no no um members
councilor Morgan then councilor White
yeah thank you Mr chairman um I was
interested in the point to speak about
there about the previous class queue is
this the uh application to convert the
existing balance uh planning reference
to one zero zero six one nine Cooper is
that that's the one so that is still in
place
that is um but we've just checked we've
just checked I think that's it that's it
that's still in place
yeah so they still have that as a as a
fallback position yeah yeah
and do you know when there's the appeal
is going to be heard
uh
[Music]
currently with pins within this goodness
knows when
um
okay
a number of these points will be
obviously subject to the outcome of uh
today's
um meeting
um will be the subject of these
discussions because the legal points are
the ones that always come up in these
cases
councilor White
uh thank you Mr chairman I mean for me I
actually think because this has class Q
approval and then there's problems with
the class queue if you don't complete
them in time
um there can be all sorts of issues we
had the ones in Hawthorne
um
which ended up being pulled down
um but for me under policy D2 part four
is the ReUse of existing and redundant
buildings and this for me hits that nail
right on the head
um I also think that it could be H5
which would be a rural exception scheme
for me already has planning permission
and I've looked through and the refusal
was actually done on a delegated not
under the area planning committee and I
think as rural counselors we have a very
high knowledge of the local sites
um so for me if there's not an
alternative I'd be happy to propose this
um application for approval because it
meets D2 part 4 reuse of existing
buildings thank you
seconded
second
and a counselor Stevens
thank you chair
um
to me the changes are just well
rearranging arranging the deck chairs um
at the end of the day there's there's a
note in there about concern as to access
onto the highway
um but the two main reasons for refusal
the proposed development by reason of
its location would be disconnected from
services and facilities and would
provide poor quality and limited access
to public transport so there's that
whole access thing
um and the introduction of two
residential dwellings and Associated
paraphernalia on the site would
represent an inappropriate urbanization
of the site I mean sorry everyone can
read that and I just can't see any
reason to disagree with what the
officers have found thank you
Mr
I don't know I just want to do that Mr
owner can make the point in terms of the
policies yeah sorry
um
yeah I'm not intimately the case but I
understand these are rebuilds what are
they
buildings um but in terms of policy H5
rural exception scheme that's for
schemes are 100 affordable
um because as I'm saying these aren't
affordable houses so that that wouldn't
apply in this instance
from D2
release
this is a demolition
all right
okay although although it wouldn't be
Brownfield
um it is previously developed land and
I'm not sure what the policy number for
previously developed land is that I'm
just flicking through them now
across the house
any other member sorry yeah just when I
just wanted to make the point in terms
in terms of class Q class Q
um is is a permitted development right
subject subject to criteria it's quite
strict criteria
um
it will allow for the ReUse of
um of Agriculture buildings
um builders in the countryside of this
nature
um where there are essentially minimal
changes it is it is it is a a reuse
of existing
structures for a new use that will
maintain these buildings it's not it's
not
um I mean just for example in submitting
an application for class queue one has
to demonstrate that the building itself
the fabric can maintain
um
um well Redevelopment in into or
refurbishment as the building itself
it's not demolition if the building was
subject to substantial demolition it
would fail the class queue test amongst
the other tests that that one would
apply
this is a clear case of uh as a full
application a demolition and a rebuild
so
the
comparison with class Q is actually not
a fair one and it's not a relevant one
in the in this particular case
um
that is part of the reason for officers
um not supporting this application
because it fails in terms of the
legislation but also in terms of
the local plan policies thank you
chairman
right okay so in a nutshell the extent
because the extent permission is a class
Q is to reuse the existing buildings the
application in front of us and the one
subject to appeal is to demolish and
build new buildings
yeah I do know about
um class Q because that's what the home
office are relying on to put the uh
Wethersfield to put the Asylum Seekers
on at Wethersfield
that's what they are using for that
argument
um
do you still wish to pursue your
um proposal counselor why given that
those policies are
not really applicable
design that um fits in with the local
Street Scene I mean the land's already
development developed for me it doesn't
I I'm it doesn't make any difference to
me personally whether it's the reuse the
buildings or they're rebuilt they're
still going to become houses either way
and if it means that we get more housing
um you know different housing we're
meant to have all types sizes and styles
of housing not just housing estate so um
for me that I'm I'm happy with this
application so I still propose approve
it under policy D1 councilor Morgan
yes I just want to add I mean Council
Stevens rightly pointed out the clause
the proposed development my recent
location be disconnected from services
and Facilities that would provide poor
quality and limited access to public
transportation I think we've got to be
realistic here the sort of people who's
going to be living in the in this
development probably is that's not
really going to be a consideration so I
think we need to be considered the
nature of the the use the the buildings
which is something we often face in the
rural rural areas Council white one last
game I think it might come back um
local
condoms of
serial detail design features and
construction methods Innovation design
blah blah blah size scale for messing
and proportion landscape setting layer
orientation so for me and we've already
got buildings on this site and I think
it does conform with policy D1 so I'm
I'm still happy to stand by that for the
reasons I've just given okay so we have
a proposal
to approve seconded by councilor Morgan
in the absence of an alternative
proposal
put that to the vote those in favor of
councilor White's proposal
three
against
one one abstention so that is uh passed
thank you very much members
well could somebody retrieve counselor
Thompson please
is she coming yeah
because you again hiding is it yeah yeah
okay thank you
here she comes
mine was white no sugar counselor
Thompson but don't worry about it
nothing no I'm
a feeble attempt to equip don't uh to
fill in the time while you sat
no no no thank you
okay members so
um let's crack on uh September Barn
Champs are great apparently this is a
call in by councilor Miss White uh Haley
over to you
yeah uh this application is plan a
planet mission is sought for the
direction of a single story rear
extension
um which would measure 5.5 meters in
depth uh 4.1 meters in width and has a
maximum height of 4.7 meters the current
submission poses no change to the
previously refused application which was
2200969 house
is the location plan
this is the existing and the proposed
block plans
these are the existing elevations
this existing floor plans
the proposed elevations
the proposed floor plans
these are some site photos
we also have an aerial view of the site
showing the property this is the
property here
and we also have a very aerial view of
you where we've added the
um area of the of the garden as it
currently stands
um as the reduction in the amenity space
for the property formed one of the
reasons for refusal on the previous
application and subsequently for this
application too
thank you very much
indeed um are we any public speakers on
this yes
who do we have speaking for this
all right Mr Stratton come forward
yeah either anyone with a microphone
um
uh you heard with the previous uh you
will get two minutes from when you start
to speak
press the press the button if you could
so that there are microphone lights up
uh good evening uh we'd like you to
consider the following points regarding
our planning application
um our growing daughter will need an
appropriate sized bedroom she currently
in a cot in her second bedroom which at
best is a box room the room will be too
small for a single bed wardrobe chest of
drawers
this small second bedroom could be then
become my study is not the size to be a
child's bedroom therefore September bomb
would remain a two-bedroom property
we have a large well-used garden to the
front of the property approximately 275
square meters which will be screened
more and more as the hedges grow making
into a beautiful private space
an additional rear Garden of 74 square
meters remains generous for our use and
any further future owners the extension
would be built using the same materials
as the original Barn making it
attractive Edition we would use forever
Regional reclaimed tiles
the extension would not be seen from the
Chelmsford road east or west
we really hope you can support us
Elizabeth Elizabeth
thank you very much indeed
uh members councilor white you called
this in so
I did this in and I can tell you from
delivering this at least they've all got
very long driveways and big Gardens
um I
was one that had uh was approved
originally under class q and it was a
bit of a an issue with it anyway it
ended up coming to us and we approved a
committee I don't recall seeing this
application so I could only think that
it must have been delegated I can't just
actually saying how it was done on the
website for some bizarre reason
um and for me it's it's a family they're
having more children I think it makes
perfect sense
um when you read the report on the
section 5.3 impact on residential
amenity
um it says that it would be located five
meters away from the neighboring
property well they're all Family
Properties it's all on the farm and
having an untidy Farm ourselves I can
assure you that it's not going to do any
harm to the neighboring land or
um area around it and in fact it will
tidy everything up so for me I think we
should support this application it's
allowing a family with historical
connections to stay in the area and
how's their growing families so I
propose that we approve this application
patient and D1 and the
um because it will protect the amenity
of its surrounding um so for me it's a
perfectly acceptable design thank you
okay well we've gone straight in with a
proposal but Council Mr Johnson you want
to uh
well I'm sure they will but I thought
you were gonna I thought you were going
to respond to council
okay all right oh dear okay council Mrs
Thompson yes
call return
because there was one Garden about 10
too small
um
no I'm sorry Frank Gardens don't count
as amenity space I know we have a
slightly wacky planning system but it is
what it is
and we're just saying 75 of the
sufficient Back Garden this is
sufficient and I can't agree sorry
Morgan
thank you chair
um I just really questioned really I was
looking at uh clause 5.2.7
this is currently proposed development
due to the size height and position of
extension proposed resulted in an
uncongruous dominant extension to the
property which will be visually
prominent within the street scene can
you please just put one of the officers
demonstrate how that's going to happen
foreign
report that we are overly familiar with
um and I've stepped in last minute so I
can't fully comment on on that part of
it
um
I mean the application site is to the
rear of the building the other side from
the street about all right what I would
say is that um this is um this is an
identical to a previously refused
application
um
the reason for refusal what reason for
refusal one it's a carryover yeah
um
sorry sorry could you perhaps be a bit
clearer
is to then go on to see how to talk
about how that relates to reading
through refusal too which I think is the
most substantive reasons
well please come back here please do oh
councilor Morley would like to come in
first yes could you go back to the
photograph that you had that you blanked
out the Garden or amenity area
so you can't actually see that from the
road anyway and
yeah okay thank you
so I think Mr Johnson it's over to you
if you're going to uh thank you thanks
thank you
um to be honest I I
there is no objection to the principle
of an extension to the property in the
rear
um the extension is fundamentally in
terms of its size and its impact on the
rear garden and I'll just draw members
attention to 5.5 of the report where it
does tend to go into a fair bit of
detail about the nature of the resultant
Garden
I'm sure this application be approved
well as a result of the proposal uh in
terms of the regularity of the space and
the potential usability of the space in
its General sense but but but what it
also does so so it sets out that you
know the the what would be left would be
74 square meters of floor space and
that's 26 less than our standard for a
property of this size
um just jump into
um
let's see uh
5.5.7
there was an application in July 2020 uh
Central area planning committee
um where a
Garden was that happened to be one of my
earlier committees when I came to the
council and I said
um that Garden was misused from
um 94 square meters to 59.7
um
that was equally a family a family that
had connections to the local area Etc
um and it was refused for the sole
reason of the garden space
um now what I will draw out there is
that the garden space on that scheme
which was refused was of a regular
standard sort of you know square shape
yeah it had distance to the rear Garden
Etc but there was the intrusion because
of the extent of the extension of it but
the result in the space was a regular
space
um what we're drawing out here is that
and if we go back to
um
if we go back to uh Five Point
five point two at beginning Point 5.2.2
um
says the existing Garden space is 99
square meters
um
and as a result of the extension that
we've used a 74 square meters which is
significantly below us 26 square meters
below
uh but then 5.5.3 talks about the
usability of the immunity space
due to the shape of the remaining space
of the garden
the interjection of the extension to the
Garden would result in a
compartmentalized Garden area so you've
just got sections
um
with the with a larger section and you
know going to a fair bit of detail here
in terms of the dimensions
7.33 meters in width with a staggered
depth of between 5.6 and 7.6 so this
gives a single regular shape of
approximately 51.6 square meters
so so the regular shape of the garden is
almost half the size of the of the
existing Garden
the remaining space which then makes up
the the additional
um
area to bring up to
74. again is set out here
so
we're talking about
um for example from the rear of the
proposed extension to the rear Garden
would be two meters
we're talking about from the side of the
uh extension to the adjoining boundary
to the east is again about two meters
so really when you're looking at the at
the regular space of what is a garden
and this is how we've made decisions in
the past so again I'm I'm bringing to
members attention consistency of how
we've approached these things you're
looking really at only an era of 70
um of 51 square meters additional area
which has been added into that also is
the is um to the east of the property
um
um along the side where the sorry to the
West
just just up along the side there
um so so this is an irregular space this
is not what the what what the policy
seeks to protect and to provide in terms
of immunity space so that's that's the
thrust of the council's gardening uh
argument and we've made decisions on and
refuse schemes for a lesser amount of
reduction
of garden space which have a regular
size thank you chairman
yeah thank you I've got a couple of
people indicated
or do we say that you're the the garden
is 99 square meters
current
still not huge is it that's right it's
30 foot by 30 foot and if it's going you
know broadly speaking
and it's going down to 74.
I mean they're both pretty small spaces
anyway but um
uh councilum White indicated but I'm
going to go to councilor Stevens first
okay that's fine councilor Stevens thank
you chair can I ask about the front
garden
um because it looks very large to me
um okay most houses the gardeners at the
back but my main Garden is at the side
at the back I've got a little Courtyard
which I'm certain isn't whatever that
sizeable we just had
um and the garden being outside is fine
it's not like it's down the road it's
just on a different side of the house
than you might expect
um that looks to me like there is a
large front garden
um it's connected to the house directly
and could readily be enclosed to make it
a safe family space so I'm interested in
that
um the other reason for objection is
um relating to the design of the
extension
the same as the one at the front
um it's got a hip bit at the end so it's
not quite so as aggressive as it might
be
um it's not overlooked
say that I agree with it being
what does it unsympathetic addition
thank you
councilor Morley
I'll take a German
um
do you not distinguish between the
private house and a farm where children
have basically the farm to play on as
well as an immunity space
I know my children hardly ever played in
the garden you know there's
we had a small garden
well yes we do I mean it's just all
intents and purposes the dwelling house
it's it's not a farm
thank you okay
um
councilor white and then councilor Hall
yeah thank you Mr chairman right now I
have actually gone into the central area
planning committee and it was went with
Meadows that was refused and so they're
absolutely totally different application
for me it looked like
a bit of an incongruous design all the
other houses ran linear front and back
on the road and this was kind of
squashed in the middle of houses that
went back to back
um and it not only had a rear extension
it also had a side extension it was a
house in the middle of a housing estate
that had
um
the two-story prediction was 5.3 meters
or 5.6 meters and the the rear extension
was 5.6 by 2.5
and a ridge height of 7.4 meters
um and for me if you go on to the site
of this development the cars are located
in a fenced and gated car park
and all of the children I've never been
around the back but I know from when I
was leafleting all the children's toys
are on the road side that is where the
children play what size is that front
garden because if that's where the
children's toys are and I I know for a
fact I saw that because I handed out the
leaflets um that must be what they're
using for their main garden and as I say
the cars are blocked off I couldn't
actually find a way to get in there so I
don't know where I shoved the leaves at
in the end um but I mean for me I think
it is sympathetic design and I don't
think there is I think there's perfectly
as he gone so it certainly hasn't got
any bearing whatsoever on the um went
with Meadows ones or with Gardens thank
you right Mr Johnson has his finger
poised to go on them
I mean our policies are based on on what
your traditional Garden is which is your
rear Garden
um we we we have to make clear
differentiating between the front of
properties and the rear of properties
there are exceptional cases and there
may be case is because the property may
have been converted from a previous use
where you may have a larger front garden
but we have to be clear in our
application of the policies what we
apply to otherwise we'll lead to wide
inconsistency in how this is applied the
messages that goes out to uh to the
general public in terms of what they can
apply for and what they would get
supported would be completely
inconsistent and not necessarily in
Conformity the local Authority could be
tied up in terms of its own decisions
it's best if if they then went against a
decision in a circumstance that was
inconsistent with the decision they made
previously on a pure where these things
where these cases would be would be
cited our modern design guide does not
make reference to the front Gardens they
talk about front Gardens as semi-public
spaces as most front Gardens are and
that's it the the the policies for
Gardens related and I think we need to
be clear about that and if members want
to overturn or made or vote to one
return officers recommendation they need
to be clear in in any minutes what are
the particular circumstances of this
site that would make it different
because we could be again setting a
dangerous precedent thank you chairman
uh well I'm going to come in there
because I'm afraid we're not talking
we're not comparing apples with apples
aren't we we're talking about
um a previously used agricultural
site
not an urban housing estate where
traditional Gardens are at the back and
the one at the front is a little bit of
a patch or a parking space so I'm I'm
sorry I don't tend to agree and I think
with there's another element here you
know we're balancing Garden space with
living space aren't we um and what is
deemed to be more important but
councilor Morgan I think you indicated
oh well I did but I think you've sort of
stolen a thunderlance sorry I mean
um and I'd you know follow with that
Council Stevens View
um I realized that the officer has to
point out the the possibility of
creating a president and I understand
that's his job but but as you quite
rightly say
um Common Sense must Prevail this is not
a terrorist house in in Malden it's it's
on a farm it's a very large bigger
bigger sort of guard the library at the
front and and plenty of plenty of room
so and the the developments behind the
the roof line from the away from from
the road I really I really as I mean I
say what I have just feel really sorry
for the officer that had to go out and
make all those detailed measurements of
the garden to be able to to for
um Mr Johnson to be so precise about
them I I really don't think they're
Germaine
well um yes and I I also appeal to uh
not only this owner but others similar
um on the light of councilor White's
comments looking for somewhere to post
leaflets
particularly if they have a drive they
should be made to have post boxes at the
end of their at the end of their Drive
speaking of somebody with an a largely
rural patch with quarter mile long
drives
and they then put a post box next to
their front door
but yes yeah
okay Mr John I mean I I think my I think
my last point to when to which you then
made a comment actually alluded to the
fact that just members need to be clear
on the basis on which a decision may be
making to this you've elaborated on that
in terms of your discussion there about
the peculiarities of this site I
wouldn't quite go with what council
Morgan's in terms of common sense but we
need to talk about it in terms of what
do we think are the material
considerations in terms of this
particular site so that's the language
in which we can understand which we can
then say okay well there are material
circumstances in this particular case
and excuse me counselor Morgan is saying
this but um you know rather than common
sense because that's that's the parlance
we use in terms of our planning
deliberations thank you John like I said
let's let's um compare apples with
apples not apples repairs because it's
it's quite different now we have a
proposal unless you want to add to it
Council whites I do want to move yeah I
was going to say I'd like to propose
a pose that fits well within the
landscape the design and character are
commensurate with the existing buildings
and materials that are in use and it
allows a family to remain in the um
existing there's no harm to the
um landscape or the street scene because
it cannot be seen from the road so for
those reasons I would support approving
this application if I have a secondary
game and that's seconded by councilor
Morley
um so in the absence of an alternative
proposal those in favor oh yes Mr
Johnson
of this particular application
in which there's justifiable means
um to not follow the actual standard
policy but that that can be
justification enough but I think that
that needs to be limited I think I think
actually Mr Johnson we've probably done
that in relation to the the relationship
between the front and the rear Garden on
this particular property yeah and if I
might come back on the local knowledge I
I know from driving in the local area
the applicants 100 use the garden to the
front as their immunity space because
there are toys parked outside the door
and a nice new post box hopefully
councilor Stevens
its own it's sufficient immunity space
so we're not saying oh if you add a bit
of the front and a bit of the back and a
bit of anti-so and so is down the road I
can make a garden it is completely
enough space on its own and it is
capable of being made into a private
secure immunity space I think if we if
we make those comments we're
safeguarding against everybody saying oh
I'll add my a couple of meters of my
front garden to it thank you and it is
in a rural setting um okay thank you so
that is a proposal by councilor white
seconded by councilman please indicate
if you are in agreement those in favor
one two three four those against one and
one abstention that is pass thank you
very much
and one more to go I think
I find the right page I do struggle with
this new machine slightly
fingers and thumbs who's taking us
through the next one
this is Hannah it's you again now
thank you so this is an application for
the erection of a stable block
Oh wrong way
so this is the application site
um you may be familiar with the site
because we've had applications brought
forward to the committee previously
um for the most recent one was for a
dwelling in um a similar Red Line area
and that was previously refused so and
then some within the further blue line
which is the only ship of the applicant
so there's an existing sheds or
Constable building within the
application site which would be removed
and to the north here is an existing um
barn and stable building that has two
Stables within it
so this is the block plan so this is the
proposed Stables
the proposed elevations
and then this is showing just the
internal elevations you can see that a
bit better
the proposed floor plan so four Stables
hey sure and sure store tack room
equipment store and feed room
some photos of the site so you can just
see the existing
stable building to the back and this is
the building that would be demolished to
make way for the new proposal
um views across the site and of the
access points
location of the proposed access and then
accessed um with
from Bull Street Green Road
which is shared with a commercial
premises
so the development if we'll go back to
the
elevation plans is considered to have a
domestic appearance and be large in
scale and bulk it's whilst the other
applications at the site have been for
residential it's worth noting that the
inspector plays emphasis on the site
having an open character and a
connection true to um truly open to the
countryside
certain so it's con there are concerns
of the fact that this could have a
residential appearance and an urbanizing
impact on the site and that there hasn't
been a Justified need for the proposal
demonstrators part of the application
this application is therefore
recommended for refusal thank you
chairman
thank you other public speakers yeah
accuse the applicant or agent
okay thank you very much
um so welcome
uh so
um
as you would be in the chamber you will
have two minutes can you add
can you see the clock
okay
all right can you see it now
it's all I can see now but uh can you
see the clock
no okay
well we'll give you I'll give you us
I'll give you a sort of a countdown then
but you have two minutes from when you
start talking so whenever you're ready
thank you good evening yeah
which will result in a large domestic
building the building has been designed
for its functional requirements there
are minimum requirements for stable
space to be provided on key welfare the
donkeys will be supplementary fed with
paint and feed
there needs to be drives clear storage
lists within the building to minimize
delivery see allocated area needs to be
an adequate size to hold a good Supply
the keeping of these animals internal
storage of other advocacy equipment and
Specialists equipped equip FaceTime
equipment pumping it is presented that
the building cannot be smaller in bulk
the third arrays are building as a
residential care Institute due to the
presence of Windows these are openings
to allow ventilation through the hay of
structures and the Stables the tack and
hand washing areas require natural light
there's connection to electricity is not
proposed as part of this application the
heart of the building is reduced in
limited 3.7 meters the actual floor
layer is commensurate with a standard
stable
application but the current stable
provision is inadequate the
accommodation of the additional donkeys
now African 63 home
but the price tiling has chosen to match
the erode with the existing bar the
windows take the form of openings rather
than glazed units the u-shape reduces
the bulk of the building which is 10
seconds
it is it is contested that the building
will have a residential appearance or a
significant
of the location okay I'll give you a
couple of seconds Grace because you can
see the clock but you did very well
thank you very much indeed
um this was called in by councilor Keys
who's no longer with us I don't mean
he's departed this Earth but he is no
longer a member of this Authority
um so members open to any comments
questions counselor Miss White
thank you Mr
um I was actually looking on the Donkey
Sanctuary thing to work out um what they
were coming from with the rehoming
requirements and but I I obviously
missed it somewhere
um where are how many hectares is the
site I can't find that
um while you're looking for that I've
actually looked down and two of the
tables are 3.2.5 meters but
um and two are three point three point
three point by 3.5 but I have to say
that three and a half meters by three
and a half meters is considered
sufficient for a 17-hand horse a donkey
is usually about 13 two hands so 17
hands would be about six foot six ish
and thirteen two would be about my elbow
height I'm not very good on where the
sizes are on ponies oh I know they're
small
um so I don't actually have a problem
with the size The Stables and I'm
actually when I'm on the Donkey
Sanctuary website it says that we they
need approximately 4.7 square meters of
covered area for their bedded area well
I think I think three by two point four
is bigger than 4.7 so um that's that one
they've got um other Heights on the
doors I think they meet the door
requirements and so really for me it's
just do they have enough grazing well
I'm flicking through the requirements
for the Donkey Sanctuary
right okay I'm rather hoping that
there's nobody living nearby because
they're the most obnoxious Sandy animals
in the world they make a terrible rail
having having had one for several years
I think
um councilor Morgan you were first
I can just chat
um yeah I I'm looking at um well 3.2 the
conclusion 3.2.1 info and says it's not
been demonstrated there's a justifiable
and functional need for the proposed
development
um which I'm puzzled by I is there a
suggestion almost the the officers that
giving Sanctuary to donkeys is not as
justifiable and functional fact that's
question sort of one and the second is I
I there's constant reference to its
residential appearance and are you I
mean are we just coming out with it and
saying that there's a suspicion that
this is some form of you know rate of
railroad through a residential
development in the countryside I think I
think that's probably where where this
has come from councilor Morgan
having having in
had a stable not too far away from where
I live that a very quickly appeared with
curtains at the windows
um I think you'll find the donkeys and
suspicious
and they actually got that on a
certificate of lawfulness after about 15
years but anyway councilman Mrs Thompson
did you
um thank you chairman um
sorry talking in old money what's three
by two and a half meters is what 10 10
by eight yeah yeah it does sound small
even to me um I'll have to confess I
haven't put 17 2 in a 12 by 12 statement
or 12 by 14. well maybe 12 by 14. unless
it was working really hard but my
understanding of having friends with
Donkey Sanctuary donkeys is they need
permanent access to walk in and out
anyway so otherwise you have to have a
field shelter I think
um
I'm more concerned about the
urbanization because it's so long ago
that we had a member and that
application was approved arguing in moat
blaming with Bishops that Stables were
not what you expect to see in the
countryside and a house would be a huge
Improvement and that application was in
fact approved by this committee at that
time
Stables are not generally held to be
domestic which is it seems Slightly
bizarre to me but that's how planning
works
thank you uh councilor Morgan
yes I'm just picking up councilor
Thompson's points about urbanization
um I believe this property is not very
far away from Broad Street Green Garden
Village so I'd rather wonder why anyone
should make a specific statement this is
this is increasing the urbanization of
the area thank you perhaps the officers
could explain perhaps the residents of
Western Park then would enjoy the
serenading by donkeys um
you can come back Mrs Thompson thank you
okay
sorry count and
um yeah so I'm councilor Morgan's
comment I mean I think that's the idea
that we keep the urban areas Within
the allocated sites and try and keep the
rest as rural as as we can rather than
mix and match the whole lot that's my
understanding
well we're going back to enforcement
members so we're not looking for a
proposal one way or the other if
anybody's going to put their head above
the parapet Council you're usually good
for a proposal well I like donkeys and I
really like donkeys so I'm prepared to
propose this um because I think that
donkeys should be in the countryside
um there is a sort of ramshackle
building there did we ever find out how
many hectares of land they have it looks
quite big
um on there so as long as they're
sufficient grazing um I'm I'm happy to
propose this because it is a suitable
building for the countryside thank you
do we know that there is
um I don't know the exact area of the
top of my head but
um section paragraph
5.5.1 of the officers report sets out
the minimum requirements for grazing
land and on assessing the application so
it's a minimum of you might have already
said this apologies if you have is 0.2
to 0.4 hectares of grazing land and
taking into account The Paddock area
then they're sufficient space officers
don't actually have concerns in relation
to the donkey welfare so that sounds
like a proposal and is that Julie
seconded
oh you please do yes
um yeah there's references
references at this but if some forward
and said all
of that they've got enough people to
occupy the extension or what they're
going to do with it it's either
compliant or not so there's something in
here about oh well it's big enough for
four donkeys and they've only got two in
mind then there's not any need can I
explore that a bit why why does somebody
have to or does somebody have to prove
that they've got enough donkeys thank
you
um
so policy E4
um supports a cocktail and Rural
diversification and that policy sets out
the requirements that there needs to be
a justifiable and functional need and
the point in relation to
the need in relationship application is
I think we could perhaps accept there as
a need for two Stables to house the two
additional donkeys but there is already
provision within the site
um there is already two Stables within
the building to the north so it's that
combined with the concern of the scale
and bulk that there isn't a Justified
need for a building of that size and
then that contributes to the character
harm
if I'm
I think
no I just want to just just uh just to
just just raise a a point about the
about the windows and in terms of the
sort of domestic appearance and um I I
will say I'm no expert in terms of
stables and stables for donkeys and that
sort of thing but uh but when you have a
look at the building and you see what
looks like residential windows is that
quite normal to have residential windows
um for Stables I mean the windows seem
to have glazing bars
um you know in a sort of regular
appearance I mean is that pretty
standard for a stable building I'm also
looking at the application reform in
terms of the materials the application
reform makes no preference to Glass it
talks about Timber
um now if we uh so that there's a bit of
a inconsistency in terms if you
juxtapose the wind that the materials
are set out in the application form and
what's on what's in the drawings
um
this is thrown out to members in terms
of considerations either way the the the
the the the vote might go
um if he went to Gaines officer's
recommendation then we have to be
considering materials I I think and
given the arguments that I hear being
made by members I think we need to be
considering the appearance the fact that
they are they are tall intents and
purposes Windows
um that's part of the concern which
offices the domestication is that pretty
standard in in my view my limited
understanding that is not pretty
standard once the windows are in there
in that regular pattern we've got them
to the front we've got them to the rear
we've got what looks like doors yep I
mean you know offices in the experience
are familiar with these as layouts uh
even for where the residential uh
dwellings come forward with this sort of
horseshoe Arrangement so these are also
part of the concerns that we have in
terms of the design what is its intended
purposes so this is the points I wanted
to just raise out to members thank you
well I think Mr Johnson we all
understand the concerns and I'm not an
expert but I don't think that you have
open unglazed windows in Stables because
the wind in the winter will whistle
through surely you must have a means of
of closing it councilor Thompson I think
you're probably more of an expert than I
I suspect so but um
qualifications writing instructors and
to be fair that's pretty standard stable
um
my windows online would be bigger and
they are prefab Stables
okay Stables equines of all kinds need
very high levels of ventilation you know
they were yeah they never evolved to
live in houses
or whatever you need to be able to see
what you're doing so
um my objections I mean I agree with
most of the office of recommendation but
not actually that part I just think it's
a large building that I'd rather see
tucked away
uh councilor Morgan I think yeah the
windows are fair enough I think yeah
they're not yeah join their are they
just follow up on that I mean you you do
have Windows in buildings of that nature
I mean they can't be sort of shredded in
darkness
um I just wonder perhaps whether there
may be a room for some form of condition
uh to be placed upon the uh the
development making that it can only be
used for the stabling of
I think we just need to be mindful on
the internal fitting Etc
that that is conditioned so that it is
quite clearly
for noisy old donkeys
um yeah I think that's fine we can
impose a condition and that would be a
standard for any Stables application but
I think the concern is the scale bulk
and design of the building and just to
add you have to point earlier counselor
about the north Highbridge Garden suburb
one of the inspectors considering
previous development in this site and
appreciate it was residential did
actually say that um
they provision of the
um Garden suburb actually made this area
of land more important and its openness
and Rural aspect because you do have all
that Urban Development to the self so
just just a point of night there
members I I don't think the officers
concerns or fears are unreasonable given
that there's a
uh previously a refused application for
a domestic dwelling on this site so
um we have we forgive them for that but
so we have a proposal are you
segregating secondary so we have a
seconded
proposal in the name of councilor Miss
White to approve this
could you show those in favor please
three in favor those against
two and one abstention so that is passed
I think is that standard conditions in
Constitution standard conditions to uh
to ensure that it is yeah and ensure
that they are um horse or donkey safe
windows
I'm talking about my material yeah
I don't think donkeys
they certainly need to be soundproof
yeah no thank you thank you very much
indeed
um oh I've gone through my script
um
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are Urgent I have none
so I close this meeting thank you for
your contributions it's been really very
pleasurable
um so the meeting is brought to a close
just missed at nine o'clock
Target as the meeting is now closed
please members you're advised not to
enter into any further discussions
when you leave this meeting and see you
next time thank you very much